a new CDC report reveals a small but
growing number of American children are
not vaccinated against any diseases an
estimated 100,000 two-year-olds have not
been vaccinated that's almost four times
the number in 2001 a second CDC report
found the overall immunization rate for
kindergarteners is nearly 95% but for
the third year in a row more parents are
opting their children out of school
vaccinations our dr. David agus is here
with more these are alarming numbers why
are we seeing more unvaccinated children
well there are two buckets these
children fall into one is parents who
say I don't want my kids vaccinated for
personal beliefs for religious
philosophical reasons and the other
growing one is access to care even
though our government provides vaccines
free for every child in the country
people may live too far away it may be
too hard they mean they'll be educated
well enough but that's a fixable problem
and can the family without insurance
than have their child vaccinated 100%
there's a program for every child in the
country to get free vaccinations what is
the danger we can imagine what the
danger is if you don't get vaccinated as
a child but is there danger also to the
rest of the population yes yes yes thank
you for that leading question I love it
you know when I can free time so tobacco
anti tobacco things happen you know it
was hard to get people to stop smoking
but secondhand smoke when it affected
everybody else in the restaurant on the
plane neighborhood there was a real
movement against it well if you don't
have your child's vaccinated and they
get a virus they could spread it to a
child whose immune suppressed undergoing
cancer therapy or arthritis and it can
kill them so part of the reasons we as a
society have to vaccinate is to help
protect others so the hope is this new
movement will be like a secondhand smoke
movement and we really push people it's
not just for your own child but it's for
other children too what's really
surprising is that 95 percent of
kindergarteners almost 95% of them did
have vaccines why is it so important to
get to 100
well because exactly that reason it's
children who can get they with the
reason we're vaccinia these viruses can
cause major problems even death and
children I want every child to have the
opportunity to grow up and actually have
a normal life without the ramifications
of having one of these
hood viruses and we can do that we have
the technology we have to push against
parents who are saying for the wrong
reason lots of these vaccines could
cause autism or other problems look at
the data meaning that the data shows
that that's not the case exactly thank
you all right it's very important
yes thanks dr. agus thank you very much